hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled improving lcms workflows
efficiencies with batch cue sample
submission and automated
data analysis i'm susie valdez of
labrush and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
sponsored by
agilent so let's get started before we
begin
i'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions
as you'd like during the presentation to
do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
click on that ask a question box located
on the far
left of your screen as a reminder this
presentation is educational
and offers free continuing education
credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
without further ado i now present
today's speaker
ryan rademacher clinical
lcms product manager at agilent
technologies for a complete biography on
ryan
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
ryan welcome you may now begin your
presentation
uh hello thank you for the uh the
introduction as mentioned
this is the improving lcms workflow
efficiencies with batchq
sample submission and automated data
analysis webinar
uh as she previously mentioned my name
is ryan rademaker
just a couple quick words about myself i
am the clinical lcms product manager for
agilent technologies
i've been with agilent for about eight
years working in lcms in one way shape
and form and as she mentioned i
i came prior to that from the
pharmaceutical industry as
an instrumentation specialist
um for today's agenda we'd like to go
ahead and first start off
talking about lcms analysis and i like
to
talk about that in the context of a
five-step workflow
each of those steps will include the
sample prep the chromatographic
separation
the data analysis data interpretation
and reporting i also like to think about
that same five-step workflow
as it goes over a three-phase life cycle
specifically the method development
method validation
and the routine analysis phases of the
of the lcms analysis
workflow
following that i'd like to talk about
optimizing lcms for routine analysis
and looking at that through the lens of
a statistical complexity or modeling it
as
a statistical complexity and where the
practical applications of that model
come into
play specifically utilizing our agilent
technology study manager software
which has features to improve your
workflow and
a demonstration as well so that's the
agenda
finally we'd also like to have question
and answer available for you as well
so the lcms analysis can really be
looked at as having five steps as we
talked about in the agenda
and each of these steps change a little
bit during the different phases
so during the method development you can
actually see sample preparation and and
sample preparation being the first step
actually is quite an elongated process
it takes up a lot of time and that sort
of makes sense because
during the method development phase a
developer would be tasked with with a
lot of questions particularly
around the sample preparation being a
new assay
some of those questions could be what's
the ideal sample
is it going to be coming from oral
fluids is it going to be from urine
crash human plasma
so forth and so on additionally they
would be looking at what type of workup
would be required for that particular
sample and also they would be
investigating
whether that particular workup could be
automated so that
elongates the sample prep
step of the method development phase
equally as long
as the chromatographic separation and
again this makes sense because being a
new assay
a lot of time is going to be allocated
uh from the developer
into the into the chromatographic
separation
because it's it's relatively new a lot
of questions would come up such as
what type of column or mobile phase are
required for this how much
sample volume is required to inject to
meet the
lod loq and what are some of the ms
parameters all of that would have to be
investigated and determined
experimentally which would result in an
elongated step
next the developer would be tasked with
determining
the data analysis for the new method for
example
how are they going to quantitate or
qualify the results that are generated
and also important would be looking at
the data interpretation
specifically they would be looking at
the data interpretation
from the vantage point of what can the
results
uh tell them and finally they would need
to
develop a comprehensive report to to
capture all of the the findings of the
sample prep chromatographic separation
data analysis and data interpretation
and you can see that each of these steps
is is actually quite long which which
makes sense in the method development
phase
but the next phase that they would be
looking at it is the
method validation phase and in this
particular phase you can see that the
first two steps
uh the sample prep and the
chromatographic separation are are much
shorter than in the development phase
and that's because
the results of the development phase
have led towards
a shortened period more appropriately an
optimized separation methodology
as well as a chromatographic separation
methodology so you can see that those
are much shorter
however any of the time that's gained or
the
time to result that's gained in the
reduced sample preparation and
chromatographic
separation steps is usually lost in the
data analysis and the data
interpretation
steps during the validation phase and
the data interpretation specifically is
elongated here because the validator is
really looking at what do the results
tell them and is there potentially any
need to go back and change the data
analysis previously so you can see those
two steps
really cut back on any of the
the time savings that are gained in the
reduced sample prep and chromatographic
separation
again similar to the development phase
the validation phase requires a
comprehensive report that's
equal in length but different
in what it's actually conveying there
too to really fully articulate the
findings of that
now the final phase of course that we're
looking at today is the routine analysis
phase
and you can see that in this particular
phase each one of the five steps has
been
greatly reduced and that generally makes
sense because
routine analysis phase is all about
repeating the same
process over and over again so you can
actually see where
where it's been it's been reduced and
we can see that each one of the steps
has been ideally optimized
and the analysis is now fit for a
specific purpose um
as i mentioned during a routine analysis
really the lowest time to results in the
maximum throughput are really
really the
the kind of the name of the game in this
particular sense there too
now the previous examples have
demonstrated that there's an elongated
time
during the earlier phases and can
similarly represent the amount of
extensive expertise that's required um
as the technique moves into the routine
phase however
less expertise is required but in order
to
continue to gain efficiency specifically
time to results
and um
being able to use the time to results it
becomes necessary to
to employ other tools in order to
continue to improve that efficiency
there too
and in order to do that um i like to
think about
modeling how to actually continue to
gain those improved efficiencies in
routine analysis
by using the statistical complexity
model
for those of you who aren't familiar
statistical complexities are a section
of mathematics that's dedicated towards
probability modeling and determining
what the complexity of individual
systems are
and for this presentation you can think
of complexities as kind of the arch
enemy if you will of of efficiency and
time to results those things
are generally inhibited by complexities
there to
are maximizing those things are um but
complexity so complexities have a lot of
uh
applications there too and they're often
used to model probability as i mentioned
prior to
in machine based learning they also have
been found to
make are often used to reduce
conditional training
in automated learning so for example in
things like auto correct and predict
about
predictive script algorithms um but they
also have anthropological learning
capability applications as well
and they've demonstrated that they can
actually be used to determine um
uh training for for humans as well there
so they they really fit the uh
they really fit the model and it seems
appropriate to apply these to how we can
actually reduce the complexity or model
the complexity inside of our routine
analysis
the complexity that we're using today is
uh coincidentally named the radimaker
complexity um i
actually i didn't write it full
disclosure um but
uh it is uh one that nevertheless works
for
for today's demonstration uh quite well
actually
um the math on this is a little bit
intimidating or it can be a little bit
intimidating it certainly was for me
when i first started looking at it
but essentially what it's saying is you
can model the overall complexity of a
system
um by determining what the summed
average
of randomly generated sampling points
are
and their closeness to the elements of
the system so
if you were to imagine randomly selected
sampling points trying to figure out
what the complexity are of a system over
the entire
system you were to come up with the sum
average the complexity could be
expressed as the closeness
or of the average of all those sampling
points to the inflection points of the
system or the elements of the system
more broadly so um
that's a mouthful what does it really
look like or
how can we apply this to it there so
let's imagine
that we have each of the steps in our
routine analysis for a single
cycle and where they would exist as
moments
on the 12 hour clock for each one of the
phase so you can see in our
illustration here we have a development
clock a validation clock and a routine
analysis clock there too and we take
each one of the steps more appropriately
the inflections between the steps and we
start to plot them
so we can see that in the development
phase we would finish up our sample prep
at let's say two o'clock um
the validation the routine phase we
would say oh we would finish up our
sample prep at one o'clock because
remember we optimized those based off of
the results from the development
phase so now you can see that in the
development phase the
chromatographic separation happens at
about 4 30.
with the validation and the routine
phase you can see that those are again
at about 2 o'clock because we remember
that we optimized based off of the the
development
similarly as we go into the data
analysis we can assume that in the
development phase it happens at around
seven o'clock
uh in the validation phase this happens
at about four thirty
in the routine phase this would happen
at three o'clock though because we've
optimized both off of the development
phase
and the validation phase and with the
data interpretation we can assume that
for development and for validation this
happens at ten o'clock
whereas with the routine phase this
happens at about four o'clock
and finally with the development and
validation we assume that we finish that
up at around
12 o'clock or midnight uh whereas with
the routine we would finish this at
about let's say 5 30.
so i like to actually model these
because it gives us different inflection
points on the face of the clock and
where they would actually fit
into that particular clock there
so let's plot the transitions between
each of these steps so let's remove the
face
uh the clock face and let's look at the
transitions now you'll notice that we're
only seeing four
transitions in each one of these phases
and that's because we're assuming
basically
infinite rest um before we go ahead and
actually start our
sample preparation and we're assuming
that we have infinite time to
to look at our report once it's been
completed there too
um so you can think about this if you
will is like i was born ready to do
sample preparation and i died with a
report in my hand if you will something
along those lines
um and we were able to do that because
we're really only looking at the
inflection points between each one of
them and that helps us with this model
we could potentially expand the model
and change a little bit but for
simplicity this this works quite well
for the example
now where it becomes very interesting is
when we actually start looking at how
complex our system is
if you remember the radimaker complexity
we talked about being the average of all
the sample points and how close they are
to the elements of the system
and i told you that in this particular
side we're looking at the
inflection points as representing points
of complexity in each one of our models
and so we've randomly selected a sample
point which i've designated as c1
and it's sitting at about the nine
o'clock position and we're looking at
that
as the largest dot or largest possible
dot product
or more appropriately the most acute
angle that exists to
any of the existing transitions that we
have in there as well
which are a ones which i've assigned as
a1
so you can see that at the nine o'clock
position and again this is just a single
sample that we have here
the development and the validation
phases show
tremendous complexity relative to the
routine
work uh routine analysis phase
and that's because the c1 and at the
nine o'clock position for both the
development and the validation is is
incredibly close to
um in this particular case it's it's
close to the
data interpretation transition that
we're looking at there too
whereas in the routine side it's quite a
ways away from from all of the
transitions of the inflection points
that we talked about
so you can see that the complexity at
this point is proportional
to the value of the dot product or the
max value that you can have
and you can also see that while the
development phase and the validation
phase are
relatively equal they're vastly greater
than the routine phase there too
and the reason that we see this
and now we know that naturally a single
measurement does not make a really good
model and statistics are really in
general
and the best model is going to include
the average of every possible random
point so you can imagine if we started
sampling at one o'clock two o'clock
three o'clock four o'clock so forth and
so on
we would get better and better models um
but still it's not
difficult to see just visually that in
the routine phase because of the
abundant
free time that exists in the latter half
of the clock that the over
that it's the overall least complex
model and i've demonstrated that with
you know just coloring in the green
crayon here too that that demonstrates
all the free time that we have in the
routine analysis there too
but the complexity of the routine phase
is undoubtedly the lowest
overall for the full time range but as i
mentioned a single data point doesn't
represent a very good model so let's
consider it
at another point so for example if we
took it at the three o'clock position
consider it when we're at the three
o'clock position as we've done here
and in this particular case we can
actually see that the development
and the validation at least at this one
data point are the least complex
of both of them so at this particular
point in the routine phase is actually
the more complex model there too
now why do we bring this up and it's
because it demonstrates an
interesting phenomena that exists in
statistical modeling
it's one of the powerful tools for the
rata maker complexities right
is that it actually shows that
complexity can be localized and
concentrated into certain areas and
while those certain areas would
generally be more complex
it's going to result in the minimal time
to results workflow it actually can
become
less complex overall and one of the
things that's really interesting is when
you consolidate all of your complexity
down to a very very brief period of time
you can actually have an overall less
complex model
even though you have more transitions if
you can imagine you could actually have
more transitions but if you consolidate
them
into a certain area if you localize them
it actually
statistically is less complex there too
so it's kind of an interesting
uh observation that you get from the
statistical models that wouldn't
intuitively come out
however the problem is that it's not
very likely so
one of the the major issues with this is
although you can localize your
complexity into a brief period of time
and
overall if we assume that it's a 12-hour
period
it's far less complex right that's
that's a good thing
the downside is it's not very realistic
as i mentioned before the efficiency and
time to results
are uh are the entire reason why you
would
do a routine analysis um and so it
doesn't make any sense that you would
simply one
run one cycle and then wait until the 12
hour period is over before you would
start again no that that's not very
likely at all
so what's more likely is what you would
see in the illustration here where
you've started one cycle
and you've actually increased that one
cycle because you've been
or you've started another cycle there
too because you know that you can
complete this within a 12 hour period
and that's far more likely
you'll also notice that if there's an
additional inflection point that's been
included here so before we only had four
inflection points
now for our second cycle we actually
have five
and the reason is is uh that we have
five is because we can no longer assume
that we have infinite rest before and
after um
previously we had kind of used that
analogy of that you know i was born
ready to do sample prep and i died with
a report in my hand
not so in this case because at some
point we have to transition from
the first cycle into the second cycle
and that requires another transition
point there too
so you can see that the complexity at
least statistically has more than
doubled
just by adding another cycle to it there
too so we've taken what was normally
a far less complex cycle overall and
we've actually just by
increasing it with one additional cycle
we've more than doubled the complexity
there too over our 12-hour clock
so that's a pretty abstract concept and
statistically it does demonstrate some
interesting things about complexity in a
routine workflow
but how do we apply the abstract concept
of our complexity to a routine workflow
now within agilent technologies we use
study manager software but more broadly
it talks about the complexity
demonstrates that
by combining the steps for an operation
that's going to be frequently completed
we can actually reduce the complexity
overall so imagine if we take the amount
of steps that we had so we looked at
four different transitions of course
going from
sample prep into or sample prep being
outside there but looking at
chemical separation going into data
analysis data interpretation finally
reporting if we're able to combine those
into a single step we can actually
greatly reduce the complexity
so again we've looked at four
transitions now we can take that down to
one transition
and our model which looked like this off
to the left hand side initially
has now been reduced down to this and
again we've received the same two cycles
but
our statistical complexity has greatly
reduced down
because now we're looking at a far less
complex model there too
so we do this by
doing automated data analysis of course
but there's other benefits to this as
well
we know that combining separation and
automated data analysis and reporting
into a single step
can greatly reduce the complexity we've
gone ahead and we've modeled that
and i think that's generally pretty
intuitive too but sometimes it's good to
see the model as well to really walk
through it
but it can also reduce the amount of
screen time that's required and the
training requirements if you remember
initially i talked about
statistical complexities are often used
in learning capabilities
well this is the epitome of that right
so we've gone ahead and
we've taken the our staff and we've
taken them from having to learn four
different
activities or four different transitions
uh chromatographic separation
um uh data analysis data interpretation
reporting if we've limited that down to
just a single step
um we've greatly reduced the amount that
we have to train them on too so it
really is a very powerful tool
and of course it's going to reduce the
screen time as well because our staff
isn't going to have to spend as much
time in front of it doing all of those
activities because we've reduced it down
the ability to schedule sample
submission if we were to combine that
for example into uh batch q submissions
around the instrument availability
combines with this to further improve
the utilization of the instrument and
as i mentioned when it's coupled with
the data data analysis and reporting
is going to significantly reduce the
time to results there too
and i like to demonstrate that with with
a standard submission so if you can
consider
what we talked about before where we
have two
individuals two technologists uh medical
technologists who would be submitting
samples you can see at the top there
the one would go ahead the first one on
the top would go ahead and finish the
sample prep
and would immediately start doing the
chromatographic separation followed by
the data analysis data interpretation
reporting
in the meantime the second individual on
the bottom would uh have all the way up
until the chromatographic separation is
completed before
they had to actually complete and go
ahead and start the chromatographic
separation
so they would have to stagger this a
little bit and actually
is is this actually represents the best
case scenario there too this is a
situation where
the individual that's on top would
actually be able to do their data
analysis interpretation
reporting offline that's a very common
workflow we produce products uh
uh additional copies of data analysis
software so that people can do that
however there may be a worse situation
where
the single workstation which is used for
acquisition chromatographic separation
is the same workstation that's actually
utilized for
the data analysis interpretation
reporting and in that particular case
you can see how the sample submission
has been
greatly elongated and the time to
results have really suffered for that
too so that's the worst case scenario
so then enter in batch queue sample
submission one of the things i talked
about is with batch q sample submission
really what you're doing is taking the
ability to go ahead and kind of uh
take up to three different or as many
batches as you'd like to go ahead and
proceed forward and you could do all the
sample prep at the same time and go
ahead and submit and really
it works around the instrument because
as soon as one particular
batch would be completed the next one
would be able to go ahead and start
so we're no longer staggering everything
in that worst case scenario and we're
actually better off than that standard
submission
as well there too so it's a powerful way
to to kind of combine that
as i mentioned within agilent we do this
with a software program
called study manager study manager is a
software program that's included in
all agilent lcms triple quad systems
and it's designed to limit the software
interaction and increase the throughput
for routine applications
um the nice side part about this is as i
mentioned it's included in all triple
quads and
it has been for a while so if you
actually have a
a system that you're using a triple quad
system from agilent
chances are you already have this in
there it's free it's included with the
software you don't have to
go through a third-party vendor to get
it and you don't have to actually
um it's not add-on software as well so
you already have it it's already free
it's included and it does all of the
things that we talked about
in our statistical modeling and our
batch queue submission
example as well it does combine our
mass under acquisition data analysis and
reporting software into a single
software program
which permits a user to conveniently
select from pre-configured methods
from a drop down menu and it fits really
well for the routine analysis because in
a routine analysis
it's assumed that you will be doing the
same thing or similar things over and
over and over again as we demonstrated
before
so because we're doing that we can
actually increase our throughput with
the study manager tool
by having drop downs of specific methods
that we know that we're going to be
running
it also has the ability to automatically
do data analysis
and post acquisition post acquisition
data analysis
and automatically generate reports
for for our our submissions as i
mentioned before it combines with
batch queue submissions so that multiple
users can utilize a single workstation
you can imagine a situation where users
would go ahead they would prep their
samples
they would set the tray into the
instrument run through the study manager
workflow
walk away because we're doing automated
data analysis
and uh reporting and their colleague
would be able to
walk up shortly afterwards with their
prep samples
submit their uh
samples as well into the study manager
software and walk away and as soon as
the first one finishes the second one
would start
and that increases their labor
utilization rate because they'd be able
to do other things there too
again it allows the entire sample sets
to be submitted for acquisition prior to
the completion of other batches so
that's where
batch q submission really fits in as
well
um some other features it has is the
ability to do work list and work
workless
import workflows so the study manager
software permits a user to submit sample
sets from existing mass on our work list
if you can think about the work list
that would have been created perhaps
during the validation period or maybe
even the development period if those are
already in place in your lab on the
workstation
the routine analysis uh or the routine
analyst would be able to select those
work lists
from the drop down and be able to submit
them or
if you have an import file so for
example from a spreadsheet uh which
could come from an lis
or a limb system there too they would be
able to import those samples as well
using a drop-down map file which would
then translate all the files into a work
list there too and that would all be set
up so that the routine analyst would
again just have to do simple drop downs
and move through the entire software
program is really designed around
improving the productivity and limiting
the steps to
from sample submission to reporting
finally
one of the other features that it has is
the ability to import and export data to
an lis and a limb system so as you can
see in the illustration off to the right
there on the screen
not only are you able to pull work lists
for example from an lis but you'd
actually be able to submit it
analyze it report it and then upload
those results
back up into your lis there too into a
report that's specific for
the type of essay that you're running
there as well so it can be configured to
both
export and upload the results into the
lis system as well as import for them so
it really makes for a very complete full
circle
workflow and able to work through
so those are the benefits um i'd like to
walk through before we go into the
question answer and just do a quick
demonstration now these are actually um
screenshots obviously from the system
i can't do a webinar with a live system
but um this was all done on a system as
well so it's effectively a live
demonstration
and what you're looking at right here is
a a
shot of a workstation that we have the
study manager program is which again is
included in all of the agilent lcms
triple quads
has been set up and configured as an
icon and a routine analyst or a medical
technologist
would be able to simply double click on
the
icon to launch the study manager
software and would
uh simply select a study from that as
well as i mentioned we
talked about work list and work list
import
types of studies there are a few others
but they're a little bit outside of the
scope of this as well
that said your your application engineer
or your uh
representative would be able to walk you
through those as well and give you some
more details but again here in this
example we're just going to do a simple
work list
only selection again
you would select the appropriate file
and work list from the drop downs that
are on the right
uh this particular work list is called a
demo work list
you can put some specific information
for traceability so for example if you
wanted to
label the the sample set with a lot
number or if you wanted to have some
information about the submitter
i've used the generic operator here but
you could actually have some sort of
unique identifier for your
your staff so that you would be able to
tell who was uh submitted the study
and uh uh what specific law they had or
any information that would be relevant
that could all be included in this
this particular page um
and then on the next following the
wizard along just by clicking the next
button
the individual would be able to select
whether they want to do automated data
analysis
and they would select from a drop down
of
quantitative analysis methods and a drop
down
of specific reporting options as well
and again this could be
reporting options that either create a a
report that pops up on a screen or it
gets sent out onto a network somewhere
or is incorporated into an lis that
could all be configured as well
the final step would be just to verify
the work list making sure that all of
the sample positions are correct
and that the methods that are being used
are correct as well it's a sanity check
a verification before finally hitting
finish
and you would be able to submit the
batch um so from here you would be able
to just go ahead and click the
you can see that the batch has been
added to the queue and the individual
would uh in this particular case they
would have to hit the start button
and that's because it's been sitting
idle um but a colleague of yours could
actually come and walk through that same
wizard that we went through
previously and hit submit and would have
uh wouldn't have to actually hit start
um that's another feature that's
included there too you can configure it
so that it actually goes into i
if it's sitting idle for a long period
of time it can actually go into a
standby position but
um assuming that you have a high
throughput workflow
um your colleague would just be able to
submit the batch and then from there
um you would just simply wait for it go
into the lab uh work on other things
your colleagues could again submit other
other batches if they wanted to
until finally a report would display or
save to a predetermined location
including an lis viewer
and that's uh relatively simple again
this is um
basically our software solution to
reduce the complexity
of your system and ultimately uh uh
increase your throughput so it's a very
powerful tool when it's used
um it largely just takes those
additional steps that are associated
with
your routine analysis out so that you're
limiting the screen time
and uh potentially can can reduce the
training that's available for it
um and also allow for batch q
submissions there too so you can really
increase the productivity
and efficiency in your lab at this point
i'd like to go ahead and open it up to
any questions
and we can we can help
thank you ryan for that informative
presentation
and we will now start the q a portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
simply click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's just get started we have quite
a lot of questions coming in already
from our audience thank you for these
questions
our first question ryan is is the study
manager available
on the ivd product in the booth
um um yeah actually yeah so uh for those
that haven't seen it
um we did uh we did do a launch or we
have a promotion of our our newest ibd
product our
k6460s and being a triple quad it is
actually it does include the study
manager
and actually even even better than that
right now as a thank you to all the
the clinical diagnostic workers there
too
we're actually setting up a promotion on
that particular product as well so
in addition to having the study manager
capabilities uh we're offering
actually three years of extended
warranty on that at a point of initial
sale for no additional cost
the details of that uh would be
available of course through your uh
your agilent representative but yeah
we're actually promoting that and it
does have the study manager so yeah good
good opportunity to kind of plug the uh
the k6460s a good
good question there yeah
thank you and i we have a ques related
question how much does it cost
oh um well it's free i don't i don't
usually get to say that in these when i
do webinars of course you know it's
always the cost and i
i have to say well talk to your
representative and they'll work with you
this is one of the few uh
webinars i get to actually say it is
actually free it comes with the
instrument
um so uh the triple quads all have study
manager included in the ivd product so
there's no additional cost for it it's
uh it's actually free
uh study manager it's now that the
product isn't of course you have to
purchase that but the
the software definitely is wonderful
thank you
our next audience member wants to know
we are getting
a six five four five xt
qtof system here shortly is the study
manager available for our system
yeah that oakland that's uh exciting to
see the the q-tops are great systems
there
um unfortunately uh study manager is
is not set up for the q-tops at this
time uh the top cutoff
or the single quads as well um
historically those other instruments
have not been
pushed into the the routine analysis
side as much as the triple quads have so
so unfortunately study manager has been
developed
um just for the triple quads and not for
the
qtaf or the single quad line there are
other opportunities though if you were
to look for things that are similar to
study manager for high throughput
uh or for like a walk-up ask type of
thing that are available on those
products
but i would ask you to contact your uh
your agilent rep to uh to get some
details about some of those other
products that would that would help you
with more of a walk up or a high
throughput
software uh for your uh your other
instruments
good question though thank you and again
thank you
audience members for your great
questions that are coming in ryan what
traceability features are there for the
users
um so let's oh that's a little bit of a
broad question
um i'm going to hope that i capture it
correctly so
in traceability i assume that um it
stems from
how to make sure that that the users are
are submitting it and everything's kind
of tracked appropriately um
as i mentioned in in the demonstration
that we did there
you can have it set up as like an sop
inside of your lab that would have
individuals log in as i think in the
example i just used operator
but you could have them actually have
some sort of identifiers that you could
use
um that's one way of addressing the
traceability as far as um
making sure that the individuals that
have submitted the samples you know you
can you can account to that
another way is you can actually have it
configured with your it group
to use your nt or your your
workstation login and it can be coupled
with that so that you would have
additional traceability associated with
it as well
i hopefully i i captured that question
correctly please
extend that out if there's more to that
thank you and ryan is the study manager
compatible
with lis middleware
um oh yes yes of course um so yeah
actually
a lot of the um a lot of the lim systems
the lis systems will frequently use
middleware particularly the lis systems
uh they uh they'll obviously the vendors
of some of the major
you know lis softwares can't can
accommodate every vendor so they'll go
through third-party vendors
uh from or middleware that will do that
and yes actually we have um
uh quite a bit of interface in that so
so one of the bigger ones
i think data innovations came up with a
driver that they utilize for it there so
it's definitely compatible but the other
the other thing that works really well
is almost
every lis or limb system has some way
to accept either an sql interface or a
csv a basic csv
file they can they can move those around
and
the study manager program can use can
use both of those
and again if they've if we worked with
that particular middleware vendor
in the past as we have with like data
innovations and a few other ones that
unfortunately
um slipped my mind at this particular
time it's possible they may actually
have the xml interface as well so
um there is an incredibly high price
actually i have yet to run into any
middleware or lis software that wasn't
able to
to interface with the system in one way
shape or form
yeah good question
thank you again and we have time for one
more question ryan
an audience member wants to know do i
have to use the automated
data analysis um
no you don't um and actually this this
comes up pretty pretty regularly so
the automated data analysis and the
automated reporting has
a lot of application for things that are
kind of the the set it and forget it
uh type of uh assays we see this
sometimes in some screening assays and
things of that nature
and they work really well for that but
there are others that do require a
little bit more of a trained eye
in the data analysis and the reporting
um and uh they still want to be able to
benefit from the
the batchq sample submission but they
may not want to use the automated data
analysis of reporting
that's okay you can absolutely do that
you don't have to
utilize the automated data analysis or
the reporting you could you could just
set it up for
for just kind of a walk-up type of
system and that would absolutely work
there's no no conflict with that
thank you ryan and thank you for your
presentation today did you want to
provide any closing remarks for our
audience
um yeah actually well first and foremost
um you know we we
called this uh venue the healthcare
heroes and i want to say thank you to
everybody
that's attended and just thank you to
all the healthcare workers out there in
general
we really appreciate it in this tough
time thank you for joining us and thank
you for
listening to our presentations today
checking out our booths
just really really
really happy to see the attendance and
the people and and just
very very grateful for all the work
that's being done out there so
i'll leave it at that
thank you so much ryan for your time
today and for your important research
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us for today and
their interesting questions
and thank you again to agilent for
sponsoring these webinars
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by this speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of the registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
through may of 2021
until next time take care and have a
great day bye